everybody the wine library setting for a
garyvaynerchuk.com mod I'm freaking out
uh hey how are you guys uh ug be calm
video
I want to talk about how old things
shouldn't be sleep or slept on don't
sleep on the old world moves something
very funny happened a couple weeks ago I
finally went out got my three GS right
and he came with some you know apps one
of them was called voice memos right we
have a guy at vaynermedia's office by
the name of David Zhang who records on
an old-school you know phone like mod
just a silly phone he records all his
stuff he's a controller so we hired him
first so agent I would tell him things
and he would take out this like little
flip get you know like 10 1994 phone I
mean it's you know luckily it's not like
this kind of phone like you know that
big but like you know you know the ones
for my five years ago and you'd like
record stuff we kind of made fun of him
right like I was saying dozen what do
think it's 99 yarn then I got this and
one of the default apps was voice memos
and then I was like you know AJ it just
it hit me I was like I'm always
forgetting topics I'm always thinking
and I'm always forgetting topics for
these garyvaynerchuk.com videos and I
hadn't been doing them as much as I want
as you guys might have noticed and
really want to get back into them as you
guys might have noticed and I need to
record some of that stuff so ironically
Maat i've been using this app and it
made me think like maybe the pencil and
paper isn't so bad maybe old school work
isn't so bad you know that's my theme
right like maybe some of the old school
stuff still works and a lot of old
school stuff is gonna work retail is
gonna continue to do well don't be
scared uh you know events parties think
about that business still gonna do well
and little things like the voice memos
can still do well mata now look at this
I want you to zoom in here MOT I don't
know how good our sound is here I'm
gonna pull it up full blast but like for
example
that's one of the things I'm gonna do
for Gary things have to come and and
which I did now did that yesterday Mott
you see you see what's going on your mom
did the goldfish too
anyway this little recorder is allowing
me to remember the videos that I want to
do and it just made me think you know we
made fun of voice recording better than
a lot of old school tactics and business
still work and and I want people to
remember that and I hope you look
forward to some of these upcoming
garyvaynerchuk.com videos I hope you're
doing well I'm having surgery tomorrow
on my knee I'm very worried wish me the
best and make sure you go out and get
crush it that's it oh yeah tissue box
stop crying stop crying go ahead and do
it see you next time